so this is the master bedroom you can
find apartments with amazing views but
affordable housing is hard to come by in
manhattan
average rents recently topped five
thousand dollars a month here and the
increases are spilling over to
neighboring communities like jersey city
new jersey 3400 for it that feels too
much already that's where this man took
to social media to vent about his
two-bedroom apartment jumping up more
than twelve hundred dollars a month this
last one here is a 37 more than 37
increase in rent he's hardly alone new
york city has historically had high
rents
but now everybody's having historically
high rents you know in the southeast in
particular where there's been a lot of
growth in it atlanta charlotte nashville
texas
the coronavirus pandemic sent many city
families looking for larger places to
live while supply chain issues and
rising costs have slowed down new
construction
a study by the u.s census bureau in june
found that more than 13 million people
nationwide were behind on rent or
mortgage payments and there are signs of
rising homelessness
michael deluca ended up on the street
when he could no longer navigate the
stairs to an apartment he was sharing
with a friend
now despite a fixed income of twenty one
hundred dollars a month he can't find a
landlord willing to take him for me to
get an apartment studio for fifteen
hundred dollars i have that forty two
thousand dollar income i don't have it i
need a cosigner i go to the people they
have to make eighty four thousand to
sign to me
they wanna make sure they're going to
get their money he's getting emergency
shelter from the city good morning
everybody but advocates say that's a
costly short-term solution we need
government support we need public
private participation to help
incentivize private capital
private partners to come in and help
solve this problem they're demanding
plans for a luxury tower to be built
here in lower manhattan on public
property be made 100 percent affordable
for working class families we have lots
of luxury we have luxury apartments that
they can't fill a building right behind
you that was went into foreclosure
because they couldn't sell these luxury
apartments but we don't have
affordability
developers under pressure have committed
to making 25 of it affordable but for
those currently looking for a place to
call home it is too little too late
kristin salumi al jazeera new york